macron après l'échec des mesures prises
et faute d'anticipation n'avait pas
d'autre choix que d'imposer ce
couvre-feu et les 20 millions de
français n'ont pas d'autre choix que de
l'observer on voit d'ailleurs que ils y
sont prêts ils sont extraordinairement
responsable puisque neuf français sur
dix accepte l'idée de respecter le
couvre-feu mais évidemment on peut
s'inquiéter de l'acceptabilité parce que
de mois en mois les français sont
contraints de renoncer à des libertés
individuelles et on le voit que dès que
ils relâchent leur attention le virus
repart les conséquences sanitaires
seront tels durable on voit bien que le
gouvernement est à la peine et que tout
ce qui est mis en oeuvre ne produit pas
les effets escomptés en matière de
maîtrise virus ya pas d'anticipation on
voit bien qu'une fois de plus les
chaussons dicter les décisions sont
dictées par le manque de place à
l'hôpital alors au bout d'un moment se
posera la question de l'acceptabilité
sociale d'autant que ce même sondage
montre que le lien de confiance s'est
considérablement dégradée puisque plus
d'un français sur deux n'a plus
confiance dans le président de la
république pour apporter des solutions à
la crise donc on voit bien que c'est
fragile
ça concerne quand même un français sur
trois ou presque
donc il y à un moment où les politiques
seront recherchés en responsabilité pas
forcément pénale ou judiciaires mais en
tout cas en responsabilité de limoges
étaient devant les électeurs nous avons
pris si j'observe que une fois de plus
ce sont les forces de l'ordre qui sont
en première ligne
elles le sont pour faire respecter
l'ordre public on les sollicite à
nouveau pour le respect du couvre feu
donc une profession qui est à nouveau
bien explosé alors de moyens c'est une
crainte majeure que ce
jug à la fois les problèmes sanitaires
et les problèmes de sécurité publique
tel qu'on a pu les observer la semaine
dernière à champigny sur marne
c'est un souci en effet dans certains
territoires on sait que la police peine
aller parce qu'elle y est accueilli par
des agressions caractérisées de plus en
plus violentes donc c'est à cette grave
sujet